la résiliation sera effective à partir
du 31 juillet 2020 puis pendant cette
étape
le conseil d'administration se réunit et
nous avons résilié pour le préciser pour
faute parce qu'il y avait une
possibilité de résilier pour motif
d'intérêt général ce n'est pas ce motif
qu'ils étaient retenus par le conseil
d'administration
donc entre temps nous allons prendre une
délibération soit pour lancer une
nouvelle délégation de service public
soit pour prendre en régie directe
nous avons voté pour que l'ensemble des
salariés et le président marie jeanne
s'est engagé il y avait une unanimité à
ce que l'ensemble des salariés actuels
esf du soit repris donc nous avons
dissipés le des doutes des salariés et
surtout nous leur avons donné une
garantie parce que cette décision elle
est incluse dans la délibération qui est
une date fondateur de droit qu'est ce
que ce sera mieux là maintenant parce
que vous savez pas en fait après un an
après avoir posé cette déclaration de
principe
vous savez toujours pas si vous faites
une régie on ne sait pas où on va on
fait tout à fait nous savons nous allons
nous nous donnons le temps de mettre en
place les instruments de manière à voir
une billettique unique est un service
public unique sur l'ensemble du
territoire y compris ce que le
territoire kacem donc ce soir régis je
ne peux pas m'avancer au nom du conseil
d'administration le conseil
d'administration sur coup nostra et la
proposition d'une vigie n'est pas
écartée